blue boom yeah i i've never been i
haven't been there since i was like in
my early 20s
like fallen somebody for the out that
hard have you do you fall people for
people that hard i get anxiously
attached to people sometimes it depends
on
if they like remind me of my mom or dad
honestly it's like it's all childhood
wounds so it's if a guy it gives me a
lot of attention and i'm not it's
usually like people i'm not that into at
first and then i'm like oh i'll give
them a shot and then the minute i bang
them or something they withdraw then i'm
like wait why don't you love me like
don't you aren't you into me like i get
very like anxious
i put my
like my
i'm giving them my i need their approval
for me to be something but i've worked
on that it's codependency it's
codependency i have the same thing but i
try to mask it so i'm really like kind
of um [ __ ] myself so i try to play
cool girl a lot when truly that's
masking my codependence right my feeling
is really like please don't leave me i
need you to show me validation right and
all of these things that's why we're
perfect codependent addict yeah so i
know it's so good narcissist
but he's not a you're not he's not a bad
narcissist no he's open about it
he's not a true narcissist because we
went through this i'm not a narcissist
at all what the [ __ ] are you talking
about so we because you're talking about
yourself i watch
there's this interview
i'm not no i we're on the spectrum of
narcissism comedians there's a there's
um you have narcissistic traits but
you're not a true narcissist because
true narcissist does not know how to
show any kind of empathy or love or
reciprocation they're only out for
themselves and they are i i don't feel
when the natural disaster happens yeah
right and have you ever had this where
you're watching the news right and you
see like oh like sandy hook
right that's not a natural disaster
the most unnatural disaster of
interesting example yeah like natural
it was crazy
so gusty that day
all right not a natural disaster right
a
sandy hook right and you know for me
it's like i remember the day
when i was watching cnn or whatever and
it was when i was watching the
playground
yeah yeah and i was just like um just in
tears yeah right and just looking at
these poor why did it bump you at the
show you were on
you're like it was supposed to be the
the mad tv was coming back out yeah so i
mean i have a sense of like i'm a human
being
be careful with that because what i
learned about narcissism is that you're
not
you're talking about being a psychopath
or a sociopath where you absolutely have
no remorse or feelings towards tragedies
narcissists have feelings in fact the
worst thing you can do to a narcissist
to shatter them is to leave them being
left because narcissism at the root is
true insecurity that's how it's bred and
because they're not
usually an adult that is now a
narcissist was a kid who was over
indulged in um praises but under
under-indulged emotionally i'm not like
that simultaneously i don't i'm not so
that's what i'm saying you do have
narcissistic traits but you're saying
leave me
see what happens
i've gotten into like i've gone in a
rabbit hole of like narcissism because i
realized like there's so many
narcissists in my family yeah and i
think that's why i'm coding we do have
traits though is what we're saying
they're yeah and i think that's
important to have that sense of
self-promotion is necessary to make it
in this industry
i think you're great bobby you've got
nothing to worry about you're working on
yourself
as long as you work on yourself that's
my criteria for people in my life if
you're we're all [ __ ] up we all have
dents it's like what makes us cute and
unique and it's cool but if you're not
working on like handling your triggers
and stuff like that i want nothing to do
with you because it's not like i dated a
guy who was had so much ptsd from
childhood abuse which i also have pt
ptsd from stuff in my childhood but you
know i work on it and he wasn't working
on it it's like when you do that you're
just an uncheap sword and you're just
slicing everyone around you like why am
i getting screamed at same oh you know
and it's it's just you know and i
understand where he's coming from and i
forgive him but i wasn't going to be
around that yeah that wallowing is so
not cute you just sit there and wallow
and to know that there is a solution but
to not take that solution right because
really yeah and i think that everything
everyone's happening to you the worst
yeah the worst yeah but i find that like
that happens like i have i i had a
childhood friend who had who now has
borderline personality and um that is
the one reason why like i cannot have a
relationship with him at all he is a
victim of everything
he he and he's so hot and cold he does
he's very abusive verbally and then the
next thing he's the most apologetic
person he's yelling at you one second
and then like just profusely apologizing
and then that's not actually that bad
though
[Laughter]
that doesn't mean borderline
sometimes people just aren't catch
themselves in the middle of screaming
and then apologize
that's true what do you guys find about
we don't fight that much but we did he
was late like i was like do you want to
come with me because i like when he
drives me and he missed the dog because
i had the dog all day
and um he was like yeah but he was doing
the laundry this actually makes me sound
so bad
andre but i told him ahead of time i was
like i'll be there in half an hour and i
was afraid i was gonna be late so
i like get there and i text him like i'm
here and he's like okay i have to change
the laundry and then it's like eight
nine minutes and i'm like how [ __ ]
long does it take to change the [ __ ]
laundry so i take the dog out he's not
in the laundry room and i'm like
screaming and i'm like
i'm like screaming and the neighbors are
like what are you doing
and then he comes and then but it was
fine it always
i'm working on i'm getting better at it
but he doesn't really do anything wrong
ever no i don't think that's borderline
borderline is like um bipolar but faster
so you rapid cycle your mood so you go
through like 10 different moods within
an hour yeah that was my ex probably
yeah
so crazy am i like that no no no no no
[Laughter]
even when he's worried about like cancel
culture and stuff he's such a sub he's
such a simp he's like the gentlest yeah
softest like i remember when we first
started dating he would always go on
podcast and talk about his like sexual
prowess with me this is before anyone
even you had even posted a picture of me
yeah and i would listen and i would
giggle because i'm like oh it's just
what he has to do pretend that he's this
like big mighty you know sexual king
when he really like he's such a simp
yeah and i love him for that he's on his
stomach
he's a real belly
boy
he's i can just imagine you're just
puckering your ass up yeah he's a bottom
he's my baby bottom oh that's so cute
i'm a medal
[Laughter]
anyway
no but
anywho
i saw something i read something about
something about how like because i had a
lot of yelling in my childhood and they
were like yelling is actually abusive
just even if you're not yelling at the
person just yelling is like surprising
shocking and abusive around people so
once i heard that that was a wake-up
call for me
and i had a boyfriend that i scratched
on his neck and i was like i'm done
like i have to like nah i have to help
myself because if i did that to him yeah
if i have kids or whatever like it just
wasn't like a safe thing so after that i
really worked on my anger and